احد الغواصين قال لي انه يرى عدد كبير من
الجثث امامه في السياره ولكنه لا يقدر على
استخراجها
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم بعد مرور اسبوع على
السيول في شرق ليبيا انقاذوا احياء من تحت
الانقاض والبحث عن الاف المفقودين في
دارنا ومدير الهلال الاحمر في درنه يقول
للجزيره ان فرق الانقاذ تواجه تحديا في
التعامل مع الجثث الموجوده داخل البحر
وفي المغرب السلطات تباشر تنفيذ برنامجها
الطارئ لاواء منكوبي زلزال الحوز ووزاره
التعليم تعلن الاستئناف تدريجي للدراسه
بدءا من اليوم الاثنين في المناطق
المتضرره
تنفيذا لصفقه تبادل سجناء بين الولايات
المتحده وايران بواسطه قطريه طائره ركاب
قطريه على متنها خمسه سجناء امريكيين
سابقين في ايران تصل من طهران الى الدوحه
ومحافظ البنك المركزي الايراني يقول ان
بلاده تلقت رساله من الدوحه تؤكد تفعيل
سته حسابات مصرفيه ايرانيه في مصرفين
قطريين
بعد ان كرس مسيرته الفنيه في سبيل فلسطين
وفاه الفنان اللبناني حسين منذر قائد فرقه
العاشقين الثوريه الذي صدحت حنجره منذ
سبعينيات القرن الماضي باكثر من 300 اغنيه
عن فلسطين تركت اثرها في نفوس العرب
ومناصر القضيه كان اشهرها هبت النار واشهد
يا علم علينا
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]